the Muslim Public Affairs Council
recently held its annual convention
topics include the state of American
Muslims conversation on European Muslims
and the role globalism plays in religion
first the 30-minute opening remarks of
the group's chairman and president
[Music]
assalamualaikum good morning and thank
you for being one of our attendees had
our convention this is our fifth annual
convention and I look forward to having
an excellent day today and an excellent
dinner this evening I will be giving a
full Chairman's report on impact this
evening therefore up my remarks this
morning will be very limited I would
like to thank all of you for coming I
look forward to hearing all of the
speakers I'm sure that we will all very
much enjoy this day thank you again and
I hereby formally open impacts fifth
annual convention thank you very much
dr. Ali um we have a special treat here
for the next speaker he's the president
of the International Strategy Policy
Institute also known as SB which is
based in Chicago Illinois SP has
recently within the past few months I
take it has officially become a member
of the impact family he will be giving a
presentation on the Islamic attitude
toward pluralism
please welcome dr. Javed Akhtar
[Music]
assalamualaikum my name is Javed after
and flown in from Chicago last night and
I just negotiated with Adina that for
each hundred miles that I flew and I'll
get one minute to speak so it was like
seven hundred seventeen hundred and
sixteen miles that seventeen I'll settle
for fifteen minutes again thank you
again for inviting me and I think this
Union we have between SP and impact I'm
sure will be productive for both groups
and I'm looking forward to so please
join me in praying with me that this the
Union will be successful now what I'm
going to do is share with you some of my
thoughts on how we can live in in the
society and how you can be productive
now I'm only be stating the obvious when
I tell you that we live in a country
that arguably is one of the most
culturally diverse in religious
religiously diverse country in the world
of true and ninety million
I'm also stating the obvious when I tell
you that Muslims account for
approximately two percent of destroy
hundred ninety million population of
course our friends at Fox would disagree
with that and they'll tell you that you
account for only about one-half of one
percent I heard William O'Reilly say
that just last week and my response to
him is I'd like to invite you to one of
my family parties and I think if you'd
come to one of my family gatherings you
realize I personally have a million
relatives in the country so I think his
his assessment would be who'd be way
wrong I think it's also true that most
of us those who migrated came by choice
like me they flew in in in the economy
class of of 747 they did not come in in
the whole of a slave ship even though I
must tell you after having flown
business class a few times the economy
class does feel like this
of a slave ship and many of times but
anyway so we are here but choice and and
and we are about a small minority and we
have to figure out how to how to deal
with that situation we are a dependent
minority and we can take one of three
three approaches one I call the Amish
approach where you could then seclude
yourself completely and say we are not
going to interact with the outside
decadent world and we'll have this as it
will follow the tradition entirely and
will really not interact you know and
and so you kind of live in Indiana and
interestingly I just occurred to me you
know it's now has its headquarters in
Indiana in a river they were thinking of
the Amish model but anyway so that's one
approach the other is we could mix with
the entire community the melting pot
approach and it's possible you know my
great-grandchildren would be saying you
know I there's somebody tells them your
name sounds Muslim they could say yeah
yeah yeah you know my grandfather I'm a
great grandfather you know he who I
didn't know him but and I knew my
great-grandmother mother she used to
pray in a funny way you know she's to
genuflect and throw her for another on
the ground and and and it's possible
that if he don't are not proactive in
preserving our identity our fate would
be that we disappear that's actually
already happened we know by by by
historical precedent and that the
Muslims who came as several generations
ago they actually have only Muslim
cultural I didn't hear just a name but
they're not practicing Muslims the other
thing we could do is we could say well
we will be confident in our identity and
will be productive and will interact and
and and so that people look at us as an
example how a minority should really
behave in this country so when you have
this dilemma obviously like any Muslim I
looked at the some examples for
inspiration so how do i how do I behave
and obviously return to the Quran and
the Sunnah and what I found was
that I cannot control the these from
here sigh from time to time after signal
to my friend over there to change the
slides because they don't have a
computer here but the I turned to the to
the serie of the prophet and what I
found was there was one phase in his
life which applies to us very much very
directly and you know I you know I wrote
a book in the Serie of the prophet
called the seven phases of Prophet
Muhammad's life and what I have done in
this book is try to analyze the
different phases I am convinced that now
if the prophet sallahu Salam's life was
like a script somebody had submitted a
movie script to produce a you know here
is what we have written they would say
no it's impossible improbable that is
not possible he can do that if you look
at for example in in one stage here he
was in Mecca he was being persecuted
under duress and then a week later a
month later he was in Medina setting up
a pluralistic model setting up a a
covenant and and that is the part of his
serie which I think applies most
directly to us at this time and I think
that's what Quran talks about when it
says a lot of the kana lakum
fear of surah LA he asserted husana then
in the example of the Prophet is is the
best example you will find so I have in
the Nets right so the the thing that
comes to mind then is what he did when
he moved from Mecca to Medina he got
everybody together they were all these
disparate groups they were the house and
the Khazraj
and that three Jewish groups the Banu
Qurayza and that the Aaron and so on and
a number of other groups and he they
won't talk to each other
they were ready to kill each other he
was able to throw his care as much for
his parent personality get them all
together and and have them agree on a
document that is a historical document
it is in the appendix of my book it has
53 clauses in it and it's called a
covenant
Medina what did the Covenant Medina do
let me just small things so that's
easier the cover of Medea said are the
principle that is central to the
functioning of a pluralistic society
that's what it did it is the first dark
it's kinda actually it's a very
important document to study can I have
the next can I have the next slide
hi can I have the next slide
this covenant is set out
it gave equality to all its citizens and
it basically it said we we accept the
existence of different different
religions in different groups in in on
an equal basis can I have the next all
the religious ethnic and tribal groups
had equal protection and rights in
dignity when they were disputes between
groups then they would be settled on the
basis of the Wadley the laws for the
defendant world can have the next so
they would live by their own beliefs so
then I wouldn't have the person laws and
judge themselves by their own laws and
help each other against any outside
threat the next they actually the term
oma was used for the first time in this
company and when the word umama used
didn't apply just the Muslims that would
live in the area apply to everybody it
said everyone the Mohajir the ants are
the Owls the has reduced of they're all
part of the same Ummah and again I read
it in translation it's Robert Graham
translation it's evening he shall see
Robert actually even his half did all of
the work evening shall simply did the
editing in the annotation so I think
it's appropriate to call it eliminates
half serie they were all considered part
of the same Ummah that's very important
next the Medina was then to be sanctuary
for all of the signatories the covenants
over there was an outside they would be
together in in fighting the threat next
so a loyalty therefore the Covenant
became essential in fact the phrase can
have the next slide
the phrase loyalty is a protection
against treachery appears many times in
the text of this of this document next
so the vamos a la Salem's inspiration of
course in all of this was the Quran
itself as has been taught very aptly
vamos a la Salim
the was the living example of the Quran
and the what was in the inspiration of
the things what inspired him
those Quranic ayahs it's part of the our
belief system you have the five pillars
in the six believe the Archon one
Affairs that you believe in all of the
previous messengers not only do you do
that but you also do not differentiate
between them and the term that is used
is la ik raha 15 the LA is is a very
important a useful very interesting term
that I use in Quran when they say Quran
doesn't say you know believe in
adjusting the positives it uses a what I
call a an emphatic negative it's a la
Achra hafidah la illaha IL allah there
is no god Brad it doesn't say there's
only one God it makes sure that you
understand clearly that there is no that
the concept there is no god but God
similarly when it says la cara have hid
beneath it means the same thing then
solano fara Cabana I had the Muslim when
Rosa Lee la oferta father can have the
next so and it goes on to say we make no
distinction between any of them la
oferta kubernetes i think we sometimes
tend to forget next the other eye which
I'd like to bring to your attention
which is again mentioned many times the
Quran has its tendency than he was
trying to to get a concept across it
repeats as many different ways
positively negatively in many different
ways and the other is this I'll and
again in alladhina amanu well is in a
harder one surah wasabi in the hard when
the Jews and the Christian the sabian
said modernity of savings has actually
lost in the fog of history they say
again it goes on to say with and those
who believe fear shall not come upon
them and neither shall they grieve
next Quran actually also tells us to
celebrate diversity okay celebrity
diversity so it's a yeah even NASA and
then again it's sort of haja wrath and
it says verily and not only does it say
that there will be different groups it
is sort of look as looking at it like an
Olympics of the righteous this is
celebrity diversity and the best among
you would
those who are the most righteous next
and in fact there is another ayah which
are like the scholars in this audience
to really ponder upon and gives me pause
and gives me and it says again clearly
if we had so wished if he'll if he Allah
Allah Allah Allah come on matin Waheeda
if he had so wished we had had a single
Ummah and it is true he started it true
it's not a single Omar we have you know
there are twenty percent Muslims
worldwide the troopers in this country
the numbers may change a little bit but
I don't see any any situations any time
in the future where it'll be all one
single Ummah next this sort of pluralism
which we had by by the example of the
Prophet as well as a friend can have
charged them with some communities you
have the example of Spain you have
example of many other communities in the
world let me use a simple example from
my own home Tom of Heather about when
the Billie University 150 years ago a
well-known University Calamari
University Heather about had the Muslim
King a minority was thinking in a
majority Hindu religion and he put up
this building next which had this is
this morning inner city building and if
you look closely the first floor has
Hindu arches in Hindu pillars and the
second floor has Muslim arches and
Muslim pillars and again he had that
pluralism mind when he constructed this
as a wonderful structure so what are
some of the caveats let me finish in a
minute and a half
caveat said if you're looking at
religious pluralism you can look at
Islamic ideology or theology from other
call it that it has been a revolutionary
and very vigorously pluralistic and has
suffered some bends because of various
political reasons but here you have an
example it connects if you look at
civic affairs how do you function in
civil society all you have to do is look
at the serie of the prophets allah salem
and look at the covenant next look at
the covenant studied analyze it and
emulated okay i think we live in
democracy democracy with the way where
all of the world will become and there's
no stopping it
but if you don't have pluralism a
democracy would be only
a liberal form of governance that can
very quickly degenerate into minority
while we preach to others next we should
also practice pluralism in our own
massages in our own communities I don't
mean just allowing everybody to come and
praying about it but I believe the
governance or the massages should be
realistic because pluralism really in
the ultimate analysis sharing power and
my last slide therefore is that that
this gives me the sort of the philosophy
gives me personally the conference in
the framework to deal with society it
makes my own belief system strong and
gives me strength I can go in
confidently and interact with others and
I believe this would provide the
framework for today's colloquium as well
it's not a confidence actually it's a
colloquium where I have a bunch of
scholars will be telling us what is the
best way to behave in the society and
thank you very much woody thank you very
much doc doctor we're looking forward to
our prolonging the relationship with SP
um excuse me finally for our opening
remarks we have someone who's well known
to the Muslim community he's a former
member of the US Army and is currently
an author for God and country the title
of his book which will be at the impact
booth he will be available for signing
throughout the day
please welcome chaplain James yeegh
[Applause]
[Music]
bismillah r-rahman r-rahim and
hamdulillahi rabbil alameen wa sallahu
wa salam ala rasulillah well i'll ahimsa
Beach Marine all praises due to a law of
God the Almighty and may his peace and
blessings be upon the last Prophet
Muhammad his righteous family his noble
companions and all of those who follow
the path of truth and God willing that
is all of us here today
first I'd like to start first by
thanking impact again for allowing me to
give a few remarks and for and by
thanking all of you who have come out
here today to join this important
conference and making this program a
success I applaud first of all the theme
of today which is examining our role in
America and this is important because I
think that this theme is an opportunity
for self-reflection an opportunity for
the American Muslim community to reflect
on how we can better help meet the
challenges that are facing our community
and the challenges that are facing our
nation but it's also a theme that
implores others the theme of examining
our role in America is that theme that
also implores others to recognize that
the American Muslim community has and is
making significant positive
contributions today despite the enormous
challenges and difficulties that have
been placed in front of us one of the
things that the Prophet Muhammad said
was for us be maghen fact while at
targes he said that we should strive and
pursue those things which benefit us and
not to be weakened
and this is important because that's
what we're doing here as American
Muslims we're striving for those things
which are benefiting our country our
community our families and ourselves as
individuals and we're not going to allow
the challenges and the difficulties and
the obstacles that had been placed in
front of us to prevent us from reaching
that excellence another thing that the
Prophet himself said in allaha yuhibbu
either am Allah a Hadouken a melon and
you know who the Prophet also said that
God the Almighty verily for sure he is
pleased that when one of you amongst us
does something that he does it he or she
does it with excellence now I'm a former
US military service member and the motto
of the army used to be be all you can be
and this essentially what the Prophet
was saying to be all that you can be and
the theme of today's convention is the
confirmation that we are here as
American Muslims contributing to the
building of this nation in a positive
way being all that we can be now on a
personal level over the past two years I
myself had some personal difficulties
and struggles for after 9/11 while our
nation was struggling with rounding up
terror suspects and putting them down in
Guantanamo Bay Cuba down at that
controversial prison camp in where in
2003 some 660 prisoners all of the
Muslim faith are being held I was sent
down there as a u.s. Muslim chaplain
serving in the ranks of our military to
serve that operation and most highly
sensitive operation and I made great
contributions
while I was down there in the ten months
I'd served I had received official
recognition and awards for my service
down in Guantanamo by the commanding
general Major General Jeffrey Miller I
had received several letters of
recognition from him as well as I had
received the best officer evaluation
report that I had ever received in the
14 years as a commissioned officer for
that service that I provided down in
Guantanamo Bay Cuba and I was down there
as an advocate for humane treatment of
prisoners I was down there as an
advocate to uphold the fundamental
American value of religious freedom and
diversity tolerance I was down there
being a patriot and I want to share a
little bit about a little bit about my
story with you and what happened to me
for doing that for upholding those
fundamental principles of value as an
American Muslim from when I came back
into the United States on September 10th
2003 I found myself in a situation where
I was stopped by customs officials and I
would quickly be arrested under
suspicions that I was a terrorist spy
that I had aided the enemy in some way
the prisoners down in Guantanamo and I
was locked away in isolation for 76 days
arrested in secrets and I was accused of
these heinous crimes and threatened with
the death penalty only after 76 days
when I was released from prison and
after a drawn-out pretrial experience
finally the military and the government
came to the realization that they had
made a mistake in all of the accusations
all of the charges that were brought
against me were dropped and they
disappeared and I was reinstated as a
Muslim chaplain back at Fort Lewis
but even in the midst of that difficulty
which I was going through I didn't allow
me to stop striving for excellence I
didn't allow me to shake my moral
responsibility as an American Muslim as
an American citizen to contribute
contribute to continue to contribute in
the most positive way and what I did was
I simply stood up for justice
ivory Tinley recently wrote written a
book that was been recently published
called forgotten country faith and
patriotism on the fire in which I have
chronicled my experiences and what it
took to stand up for justice and what it
took for me as an American Muslim to
stand up and fight and advocate for
those fundamental American values of
diversity and tolerance and religious
freedom I recently resigned my
commission from the US military I'm
extremely proud of my service to this
country and after receiving my honorable
discharge in January of this year in
addition to another army commendation
medal I completed the writing of my book
and documenting of my experience in a
manner in which my intent was to
continue to contribute to the building
of this great nation the theme of
examining our role in America is one
that as I said allows us to realize and
reflect on how we can better meet those
challenges and it's a theme that is
imploring others to recognize the
positive contributions that the American
Muslim community is making today and
that we are ready to continue to make
challenge to meet those challenges and
to continue to make those great positive
contributions every day with that I want
to keep my comments short and again I
thank you all for coming and
and allowing me to share some of my
thoughts and give some opening remarks
today deductible affair my name is
brother James use of Yi I'm your brother
and Islam and your brother in humanity
assalamualaikum got a lot everybody now
the current state of the American Muslim
community this panel is about ninety
minute so this first plenary the title
is the state of the Muslim American
community and the monitoring moderator
is someone who the Muslim American
community here in Los Angeles and
nationwide as someone we are very well
aware of and we consider him a family
member to many of us dr. Maha toot
thank you Milagros manner ahim
alhamdulillah
salat wa salam ala rasoolillah we are
trying to keep a good tradition in
impact to start on time and end on time
and so i will delete my remarks but i
want to share with you my problems about
that
lately they they say that i whine a lot
i have i have two problems one problem
with the planet
they are great speakers so I will
agonize to try to limit them to the very
inappropriately short time that is given
to them but we will try to keep the time
within the limits you will forgive me
and I am sure they will forgive me I'm
not I'm sure about them not sure about
you you will forgive me when I cut them
short if I have to also one times the
question and the answer comes I'll also
ask you to be very concise and if you
exceed will pull the plug as we say in
medicine the the speakers we have are
our very distinguished in different ways
I will probably start by dr. Purvis Anat
dr. Hamid is the chairman of the sister
organization care as all of you know
they are doing a fantastic job in
defending American civil liberties
I will probably start by dr. Parviz Anat
dr. Hamid is the chairman of the sister
organization care as all of you know
they are doing a fantastic job in
defending American civil liberties and
[Music]
[Applause]
we share a harmony of work and synergies
that I hope will become the model for
different Muslim organizations I will
not go through the bio of dr. Amin in
detail he is a researcher and the
teacher of finance at the University of
Florida that explains the good money
they have at care
he writes operates in almost every
respectable Journal particularly in the
west coast and the East Coast and in the
south he won the Civil Liberties award
of two or two from South and Central PA
Chapter of ACLU and others and others
and others dr. Hamid please come
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bismillah r-rahman r-rahim wa salatu
was-salam ala rasulillah kareem thank
you for to the Muslim Public Affairs
Committee Council for inviting us to
give a very brief remark over here and
my special thanks to dr. Haddad for his
exemplary leadership not just of this
organization but to the American Muslim
community
he has been an inspiration to many of us
for for many decades and also my deep
appreciation for this distinguished
panel over here and especially dr.
sulemani on who his wisdom and his
thought on this subject has guided us in
also shaping many of the policies and
programs that is not only part of care
but also part of many other Muslim
organizations time is short so I'll just
touch upon the highlights of this topic
and the topic that I specifically want
to address is American Muslims
integration and decent
disenfranchisement over a thousand years
the discourse primarily in Europe and
subsequently in America has been to view
Muslims as outsiders and Islam as the
other this attitude is despite the fact
that for 700 years Muslims had a
civilizing presence in Andalusia or
Spain and this despite the fact that
Islamic Spain was multicultural even
before the word multicultural was
invented and this despite the fact that
there was an exemplary convivencia
between Muslims Christians and Jews
managing not only to get along with each
other but actually creating one of the
most brilliant civilizations for ages
and this despite the fact that Muslim
contribution played a significant role
in creating the civilization of Europe
that at its height smash the Roman
Empire and Italian Renaissance
all of these facts are true but given
all of this
the unfortunate fact is that Islam and
Muslims remain in Europe and in America
embedded in stereotypical assumptions
and misguided pronouncements regarding
beliefs attitudes and customs the
contemporary reality suggests that
Muslims can no longer be viewed as
Outsiders is substantial Muslim presence
in the West
combined with the unstoppable forces of
globalization require a new paradigm for
engagement we can no longer talk about
Islam versus the West but rather use a
new frame of reference such as Islam in
the West or Islam and the West rather
than be viewed as cultural as insiders
the Muslim presence must be embraced as
culturally enriching and economically
benefiting and thus at the very onset we
need to debunk Samuel Huntington's
premise that there is an intrinsic clash
between intrinsic clash between Islam
and the West and his thesis of Islam's
so-called bloody boundaries because
these expositions of Samuel Huntington
are simply in our view an errant reading
of the realities as grand fuller and en
lesser in their book a sense of siege
very aptly portray that Islam as a faith
is not on a collision course with the
West and we also need to draw attention
to the fact that Islam is not any
monolithic entity Islam does not
constitute a single entity there is a
tremendous diversity and pluralism that
dr. doctor talked about in his opening
remarks that has to be addressed and
acknowledged not only in our own
interaction with each other but also
with our interactions with the rest of
the world Muslims from the very dawn of
civilization or the very dawn of Islam
has lived in harmony with large within
large multicultural societies as dr.
Rutter's presentation very aptly pointed
out the Muslim multicultural framework
at the time of the Prophet sallallaahu
alayhi Salaam in Medina and which the
most tangible evidence that is in our
hands today is the Covenant or the
Charter of Medina
the fact that Muslim minorities whether
they live in the West or the live in the
West leave in the air live in the East
they live in theological congruence with
the Quran because the Quran says in
chapter 2 verse 115 - God belongs the
east and the West wherever you turn
there is the presence of God so this
dichotomy that we set up Western Muslims
versus Eastern Muslims or West versus
the East is not really theologically
grounded in the Quran because the whole
of Earth belongs to allah subhanaw taala
and the Islamic presence has forever and
ever been in all parts of the world and
it will continue to be in all parts of
the world and the Muslim minority
experience whether it is today or at the
birth of Islam 1400 years ago continued
to be shaped by the seminal seminal
birth of Islam Islam started as a
minority religion so for us the minority
experiences living in the West or from
where I come from living in the East I
was born in India the Muslim minority
experience continued to be shaped by the
prophets analyst Liam's example in the
first 13 years of his life or what we
call the Meccan period but when you look
at the Muslim minority experience it's a
very interesting minority experience
Muslims have ruled as minorities it's
definitely in India and in many other
parts of the world Muslim Spain and
others and if we look at the Muslim
minority experience it spans the gamut
from being just rulers to oppressive
tyrants from being celebrated citizens
to being despised ridiculed and hounded
so with this rich backdrop in history
the Muslim presence in in the West today
and specifically in the United States
presents a challenge and an opportunity
that was on an unimaginable even a
decade ago the American Muslim community
as we all know has seen remarkable
growth from one congregation in the mid
1920s to over 2,000 congregations or
organizations of various functional
types at this point in time the American
Muslims are experiencing life as part of
an increasingly globalized
all indications suggest a growing
momentum among Muslims in favor of
integration into America's civic and
political life mainstream Muslims
consider poor American values to be
consistent with normative Islam chief
among these are the norms - hard work
entrepreneurship liberty civilian
control of the military clear
institutional institutionalization of
political power a diffused process for
making public decisions a functional
civil society that gives voice to
competing interests within a country the
American Muslim community is unique in
its diversity 36% of American Muslims
were born outside the United States
while 60s re 36% of American Muslims
were born in the United States while 64%
of us come from 80 different countries
no other country in the world has this
rich diversity of Muslims as dr. dr.
Kurt perceptively mentioned no other
country in the world has a rich
diversity of of religions and ethnicity
but even within the Muslim community no
other country in the world presents this
rich diversity of ethnicity thoughts and
views the American Muslim community is
thus a microcosm of the Muslim world it
includes all religious schools of
thoughts intellectual trends political
ideologies and Islamic movements and
this by itself presents a tremendous
challenge but in my view presents a
tremendous opportunity of interaction
and development and cultural enrichment
by which we can not only benefit the
community but also benefit the society
at large we all know that the three
major ethnic groups in the American
Muslim community are South Asians Arabs
and african-americans with about South
Asians 32% Arabs 26% and
african-americans about 20% Muslims from
various various African countries
constitute about 7 percent of the Muslim
community and there are more Muslims
that came from Pakistan about 17% than
from any other country
the Muslim community is also younger
better educated and better off
financially than the general public now
here are some reflections on the
integrative attitudes of American
Muslims in a survey that has been done
quite a while back over three-quarters
77 percent of Muslims reported that they
have been involved in organizations that
have helped the poor the sick the
homeless or the elderly 71 percent have
been involved with the religious
organization or a mosque and over
two-thirds of 69 percent have been
involved with school or youth programs
little over half of those surveyed 51%
also stated that they had called or
written to the media or to a politician
on a given issue or had signed a
petition the majority of Muslims 58
percent believed that individuals
businesses and religious organizations
in their communities have undergone
discrimination since 9/11 despite this
fact an overwhelming number 93 percent
favored participation in the American
political process almost the same number
also support or also support the idea of
contributing financially to non Muslim
candidates and social service programs
but despite these integrative attitudes
we cannot escape the fact that there is
a significant rise in anti-muslim
sentiments in this country which is
hindering the progress of integration
and also hindering creating tensions
between the American Muslim community
and other communities we know these
facts the rise of anti-muslim sentiments
in this country the Pew foundation poll
showing that almost 4 in 10 Americans
have an unfavorable view of Islam the
ABC News poll that shows that the
public's attitudes towards Islam is
becoming increasingly hostile 14 percent
after 9/11 Islam encourages violence
today it's 34 percent so although we are
far removed from 9/11 the public has a
greater misunderstanding of Islam today
when it had immediately after nine
if you look at care civil rights report
you can see double digit triple digit
increases in discrimination and
unfortunately hate crimes if you look at
cares fall 2004 poll it shows that 1
more than 1/4 of the survey respondents
agreed with stereotypes such as Muslims
teach their children to hate or Muslims
value life than value life less than
other people when asked what comes to he
what comes to mind when they hear the
word Muslims 32% of the respondents had
a negative comment and only 2% only 2%
had a positive view and all of these
negative attitudes matter because these
negative attitudes reflect into
something that is of immediate concern
to us which is our civil liberties the
Cornell University poll that was done
last year shows that 44 percent believe
44 percent of our fellow Americans
believe that some curtailment of civil
liberties is necessary for Muslim
Americans something that would not be
applied to any other community a
significant portion of Americans have no
problem in saying or believing that our
civil liberties should be curtailed 29%
agreed that under undercover law
enforcement officers should infiltrate
Muslim organizations and this is
particularly relevant given the news the
current news about President Bush
authorizing surveillance of Americans
and my time is almost up
so in conclusion of course this is a
this is a this is a huge topic and and
and certainly cannot be done justice in
the short time that we have but one good
news out of all of this is that rather
than be cowed by all of this negativity
and all of these attitudes around us the
Muslim American society and the
community has responded with a lot of
positive energy your presence over here
is reflective is reflective of that
positive energy but Muslims Americans
have done a lot of outreach efforts in
trying to overcome the negativity about
Islam and Muslims
I can only cite the activities and
projects that Kerr has undertaken but
I'm sure many other organizations can
put up an equally impressive list of
items that
have done for example the Koran project
after 9/11 or after the Guantanamo the
suppression news came out our care
responded by offering a free Quran to
anybody who calls our office to request
one over 25,000 Americans have requested
a free copy of the Quran seventeen
thousand have received them by today and
there is a very positive response from
the people who are receiving this Quran
for the first time having an opportunity
to read a copy of the Quran
similarly the library project where over
8,000 libraries have now been provided
books authentic books or well written
books about Islam and Muslims the ad
campaign the PSA campaign in other words
in short the Muslim community is not
taking this attitudes passively they are
responding and which is a positive sign
towards their empowerment and their
integration so in conclusion I will
simply leave you with two words of
advice coming from two of our role
models one is the prophet prophet Salla
Vacek
our prophet muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam himself where he said that you
were all custodians and you will be
questioned about the things under your
custody in other words there is a great
deal of responsibility on all of us in
this room the responsibility is not on
the people on this podium or the people
that he will hear from throughout this
this wonderful convention but it is on
each and every one of us we have a
responsibility and an obligation to
respond and continue to respond to this
negativity in a positive manner and the
last comment or the last coat that I
will share with you comes from ali
radiya llahu and when he sent malik me
rushed her to become the governor of
Egypt and I think this Court will
summarize our attitudes towards this
this situation our situation today this
is what Ali advised Malik as he was
being dispatched to become the governor
of Egypt he said no no Oh Malik that I
am sending you to a country that has
been subjected before you to both just
and unjust rulers so the people will
judge you in the same way that you stand
in judgment of your predecessors
therefore let good word
be your true assets discipline yourself
covered not that which is not rightfully
yours train your heart to feel
compassion for the people to love them
and be kind to them do not behave like a
ferocious beast towards them snatching
away their sustenance for the people are
of two categories there are either your
brother in religion or your fellow human
beings
[Applause]
thank you very much in his rushed
valuable presentation dr. Amin
highlighted several important things he
said that unfortunately in the last 1000
years
Muslims in the west where you used as
well top perceived as the other that's
in spite of a history that should have
divided that divide that we he also
indicated that we live at a time of
globalization
there should be no collision and no
clash and this is an opportunity that
Muslims here are a microcosm of the
Muslims in the world and there are
opportunities that come with that
he definitely indicated how minority
being a minority can highlight the
values of universality and also he
offered the very valuable statistics
that I'm sure he can make them be
available to you the the second the next
speaker is a person that I described
adequately in Chicago as a person who
does not give a talk he plays an
intellectual Symphony and
professors man yang is that person the
only drawback is that we don't have a
time for a symphony so we'll ask him
just to play solo and dr. yang I am sure
all of you already know him he is a
professor of African Studies at Howard
University
he is probably on the advisory of every
respectable Muslim organization in
America I don't think that there is one
that will not grab him for advice and if
there is such a one then this one will
not deserve his advice then he was
originally a diplomat was ambassador and
the head of Chancery of Gambia of
Gambian Embassy in Jeddah Saudi Arabia
then he went to academia and since then
he has been enriching Islamic thought
and the Islamic activist dr. Lanyon and
I'm sure I asked again for your
forgiveness that I'm going to limit dr.
Hsu a man for only 13 minutes or so
I always be believen as a Tana regimes
Bellerophon rahim it's led to Islam
other Rasul Allah said when eli Denardo
glossary color or said of unknown
[ __ ] Abdullah Saleh Aslam o
alaikum and greetings to all of you who
are not Muslims but our friends of
Muslims and you are here I will say good
morning to all of you it's a great
pleasure to be here in the company of my
colleagues the table here all of them
are very accomplished in their own areas
and they are doing their very best for
the Muslim society and I hope that we
will be able to see how with you our
thoughts since I'm going to speak again
I'm gonna give you an appetizer and
hopefully we'll make sure that you come
for the whole cause later on in the day
when we talk about the state of the
Muslims in the United States we can look
at it historically sociologically
politically and economically you have
heard from the chairman of the board of
care which is one of our primary
organizations in monitoring what is
happening to our community so when he
gave you his report he's giving you a
State of the Union State of the Union
for Muslims just like when you hear at
the end of this meeting the Proceedings
of all this presentation from impact you
will get a state of the union of the
Muslim community within the American
Society something that our foreign
leaders do every year to tell all of us
Americans where are we and where are we
going
so let us now look at the historical
record with regard to the Muslim
community here I think the Muslim
community was sailing along very well
before 9/11 so from a historical point
view we have to look at three 911 and
post 911 and in a very short time I will
just give you some markers for you to
think about and then of course in your
own research because we educated you
will be able to confirm or negate some
of the things that are put forward
before you first of all if you look at
the Muslim community you will notice
that the Muslim community has been able
to make tremendous progress in America
no other immigrant group has been able
to accomplish economically within a very
short time as has the Muslim community
this is likely because the Muslim
community in America is very different
from the community in Europe the Muslim
community in America are the children of
the Cold War if you want to get index of
this you live in California before World
War two there were less than 50
Vietnamese in this country as a result
of the Cold War since 1945 we now have
over a million Vietnamese you live in
California you can verify that now if
you look at the number of Muslims in
America before World War two you will
see that the Muslims were very tiny
minority in fact I used the metaphor of
a needle in a haystack
you will not find many Muslims at that
time but since the Cold War the number
of Muslims have multiplied remarkably to
the point that you had what dr. Parviz
mama told you that you now have in the
United States Muslim from 80 different
countries something that the Maps
project winds up we did the survey found
out today it is only in America that you
can go to a Masjid in the major cities
of the United States where you will have
an Albanian and Afghan and Algerian
alphabetically Bengali Bahraini all the
way up to Yemen and Zanzibar only in
America now there's a good index from a
historical point of view in terms of how
far we have traveled that Allah in his
wisdom has decided over the last 50 to
60 years
to assemble all of us as if he assembled
all of us for you Maruyama and the
example for Muslims is the Hajj when you
go for Hajj you have Muslim from all
points on the globe the fundamental
difference between the American Muslim
experience and the hajj experience is
that in America it is 24/7 you live in a
geographic zone where these Muslims live
as fellow Americans
whereas in Saudi Arabia they have Saudi
Muslim host and the rest are Muslim
guests from other parts of the world
here you live together as Americans and
Muslims there's a very fundamental point
to take into account here
the second thing from a historical point
of view is that since 9/11 the Muslim
situation in the United States has made
the Muslim the most visible minority see
in America minorities tended to go
through a process of transformation
until they melt into the larger society
that's why scholars came up with the
concept of the melting pot which was
very much an idea that developed after
the civil war we do migration of a lot
of people coming out of the Slavic zones
of Europe and southern Europe so you now
have this gradual melting of the groups
the Muslims we are coming to this
society from the Arab world from South
Asia Central Asia Southeast Asia and
those of you who have read some of the
things I have written and if one heard
that
and others you know that whole history
what I want to say in this brief moment
we have here is that if you look at the
historical record you will see that the
Muslims in the United States are not
only very diverse to the point that we
have the replica of the Hajj and as you
heard from dr. pave our that the Muslim
community is not only over in 78 80 %
but the Muslim community comes from
every complexion now what is unique
about the Muslim community here in the
United States is that the Muslim
community here is
very affluent we have over $40,000 in
terms of the household income of
families above if you go to the library
you look at encyclopedia of American
religions and you look at the figures
for the various groups you will see that
the Episcopalian Jews and others the
Muslims are high up there in terms of
earning power and this is likely because
they are the children of the Cold War
they came to America and they study and
many of them never went back they were
kept in America because of what I call
conjugal entanglements they get married
here so for that reason they are here so
from a historical point of view you can
see that you are part of a community
that's a microcosm of America in terms
of racial differences it's a microcosm
of the Muslim world in terms of
diversity of the Muslim world both
languages and in terms of sectarianism
as dr. Hamid points out to you now let
us look at the sociological reality on
the Muslim community in giving a report
card for the Muslim community from a
sociological point of view we have two
kinds of Islam
we have suburban Islam and inner city
Islam in a city Islam predated suburban
Islam in the sense that inner city Islam
goes back to the founding of the Mauri
science temple and the Nation of Islam
these proto scholars will call them
proto Islamic or Islamized not Islamic
religions but the Nation of Islam has
grown out of its old mode on the de
leadership of imam warith deen muhammad
to the point that today if you look at
the muslim journal you will see a Quran
on the one side and you see the American
flag and the other showing that the
african-americans who came out of that
experience have now assert the identity
that the Americans are Muslim at the
same time whereas under the old nation
of islam
it was a system challenging group now
what has happen is in the inner city of
the United States you still have
Muslims whether they're of the Nation of
Islam under Farrakhan and they are
gravitating towards Orthodox Islam they
still on the way and then you have the
nation I mean the Nation of Islam that
has been changed by Imam Ali Mohammed so
you can see from a sociological point of
view that there is still inner-city
Islam we regard to those groups and you
have a number of subgroups under that
category we don't have time to go for
that given our reality but then you have
suburban Islam suburban Islam is a
result of the success story of Muslims
Muslims came to America and they became
doctors and engineers to the point that
in certain parts of the United States
today you find like number of Muslim
scientists and doctors and engineers and
businessmen and one good index that the
Muslims have arrived and my friend
prover dr. Java doctor spoke as a leader
of FC SP and how it is he is now very
much working with impact you can see
that now what you find is that you find
in places like Chicago Muslims are not
only organized in terms of establishing
institutions such as massage its Islamic
centers schools businesses halal
restaurants and all the others but you
are now beginning to see that Muslims
are now also beginning to assert
themselves as Americans and they're
feeling secure food those who are from
South Asia among those Hydra bodies one
good index that they have now developed
some kind of psychological comfort in
being American is that now among Muslim
from South Asia if you want to know that
we have like number of Hydra bodies they
will call that City
Chicago's reef Los Angeles reef Houston
Sharif so you know that they are now
comfortable and you can see that among
the Iranians to the point that Iranians
who live in Los Angeles and you know
this very well you live here the
Iranians who live here they will call
this place tear Angeles that's how they
call it if you
Runyon they call displays tehrangeles as
your Iranian friends they tell you this
is Tehran jealous because they're
feeling comfortable in Los Angeles to
the point that this city's the
second-tier on their angeles now the
reality is when you look at the
community you see that the muslims are
now beginning to establish themselves
very well here they're beginning to feel
comfortable in america the other point I
want to raise with regard to economics
is that if you look at the economic
situation among the Muslims you can see
that we have a Tale of Two Cities
Muslims living in suburbia and Muslims
living in the inner city now one major
challenge for Muslims and this is
something that the president as states
would do with regard to the country when
he gives the State of the Union and of
course the leaders of all these national
organizations whether they are Catholic
Jewish protestin or air orders they also
try to see where they have gone through
major fundamental sociological economic
challenge every community is to build a
bridge between suburban Islam and inner
city islam scholars have studied these
to society communities you know like you
have a doctoral dissertation that came
out as a book talking about chicago as
muslim medina
so i mean Chicago as a Medina forums so
I think what we have to recognize at
this juncture in our history is that the
inner city Islam and suburban Islam must
be bridge and that bridge has to be done
by organizational suggest impact is not
ignorant all the others they have to see
this as actually the last point I want
to make is a cultural thing when you
look at the situation now for Muslims in
spite of 9/11 and in spite of the
Patriot Act
Muslims are still making progress in
various aspects of American society
there are problems you know we just have
one of our colleagues were supposed to
come from England having a problem over
there so that means to say the problem
we haven't really gotten out of that
dragnet yet but the reality is Muslims
have made tremendous progress so if you
look
at the situation from a historical point
of view sociological point of view
economic point of view and cultural
point of view what you have to recognize
is that the Muslims are now beginning to
impact the English language to the point
that now Muslims just like the Jews are
beginning to imbibe into English certain
words like halal you see so Muslim would
like to go to baseball and they would
like to attend football but you cannot
if they can get halal they would prefer
that when they go to the baseball so
Muslim enterpreneurs would be selling
Halawa d'oeuvres but if they cannot get
that they'll get kosher now what is
beginning to happen is that the Muslims
in America are also beginning to begin
to be are also beginning to impact the
English language to the point that some
of the young creative Muslims such as
our comedians are beginning to make
humor very much part of American reality
and they are also beginning to inject
into their human set in terms that are
coming from various Muslim languages
into the English language and this is
how you give to get American society to
approve to the point that as I always
tell so many students this story I
encounter when I came here at UCLA many
years ago to give a lecture talking to
some Arab kids and some Muslims and from
Pakistan and others white Americans and
African Americans in the audience I was
saying to one of the kids that you can
piggyback on the other student and then
all of a sudden he said no dr. yang you
should not say piggyback you should say
camel bagging so you can begin to see
how language is beginning to be changed
by Muslims so in this regard what is
beginning to happen in our community is
that if you make a state of the union of
Muslims you can see that politically the
Muslim community it is making some
progress on the very difficult times and
this is the job that politicians in the
country are trying to deal with these
American civil liberties and many other
groups that are concerned about rights
and liberties of fellow Americans have
been very active
in this regard care has been very active
and Muslim lawyers have organized
themselves also to respond to this
challenge Adi from a historical point of
view one thing that has to be recognized
is the fact that studies done by mobs
studies by done by the Center for
Christian Muslim understanding studies
don't buy care because we have one of
our colleagues there in the research
department who came out of a book came
out with a book on on Muslims in America
and of course giving a progress report
on the situation so what we can say
really is that the Muslims are here to
stay and as I will elaborate when I
speak again the myth of return has been
exploded the parents always thought
about Karachi Beirut Cairo etc because
that's the team that plays in their head
the tape that plays in the head of the
young people here it's Los Angeles Los
Angeles Los Angeles so those kids are
not going anywhere this gonna stay here
so for that reason when we give instead
of the Union for Muslims we must say
that the Muslims are here to stay and in
spite of all the difficulties created by
9/11 they are not going anywhere they
are going to use the American
Constitution to fight for their rights
and they will make sure that terrorism
will not be associated with Muslims in
the long term just like Italians have
fought very hard to make sure that the
Mafia connection is eliminated thank you
very much
we are told you that my job is is not
easy it is even going to be more
difficult with the next speaker 18 a
lack of each one of our own because when
I cut short the other speakers they will
travel when we cut her short she stayed
with us and we'll hear about it forever
I am so delighted to introduce Adina to
you Adina is very much enjoying being on
the panel because she had an opportunity
to sit down she has been on the run for
two continuous days preparing for the
convention Adina is our communication
director impac a lady with multiple
talents spoke all over the all over the
world almost she even went as far as
Malaysia representing a very important
point of views about Islam and about the
role of Muslims in the West she appeared
on almost all the media she wrote
extensively and she is finishing her
master's degree in communication from
Pepperdine Edina
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one that sounds about right
so then why take them may the peace and
blessings of God be upon you in the name
of God most gracious most merciful it is
my task today to deliver the State of
the Union for the American Muslim
community for the youth in the American
Muslim community in a very brief 12
minutes I'm a person full of pragmatism
and I will cut straight to the chase
when we look at who we are as an
American Muslim community certain things
are certain
one is that we know that our numbers
range anywhere from five to eight
million depending on who you talk to
depending on who else you talk to it
could be one to ten million but studies
have shown a 2002 Cornell study showed
that 40% of American Muslims are under
the age of 29 40% of American Muslims
are under the age of 29 I have about six
months left of my membership into that
category and from that position I offer
you the following analysis first I ask
you a fundamental question if 40% of the
American Muslim community are under the
age of 29 why aren't 40% of our speakers
and our leaders on the national stage
people who are under the age of 29
the youth in our community today deal
with fundamental and conflicting issues
of identity of Islamic education and of
questions of civic participation they
face a number of conflicts that have
been only further exacerbated by 9/11 we
are truly the 9/11 generation not only
those who are in their 20s and 30s and
40s and so on but specifically those who
are in the K through 12 educational
system and who were in college they are
on the front lines of representing our
faith our faces and our voices to the
broader community what they say how they
view themselves and where they see their
role within their nation will define how
their colleagues their peers to will see
Islam and the future of Islam in this
country that's a heavy burden for a very
young population and a very ill-equipped
senior population and I say ill-equipped
in the sense that we are dealing with a
variety and a plethora of cultural
issues that can destroy us if they are
not addressed head-on and unfortunately
what we see sometimes in our own
community is that these issues are
sometimes too hard too sticky too
complicated too gray to deal with
head-on so instead they get swept under
the rug you know in decades past when I
was growing up it was you know questions
of dating questions of alcohol those
were simple questions compared to are
you an American and a Muslim
simultaneously how do you view Islam on
the international stage what does jihad
mean to you the kinds of questions that
we are now dealing with are so complex
and so challenging to this to a young
psyche that we can no longer afford to
ignore them or to put them off and
unfortunately I believe that that's what
we have done for far too long and that
really needs to change our Muslim
community it can be roughly divided and
I this is a
Division of convenience rather than of
intellectual vigor into two categories
the first that I would describe is that
of the immigrant Muslim the the children
of immigrants the second that I would
describe or that I would categorize
would be the children of indigenous
Muslims and then there's another third
category which is the convert population
and that fits within both categories
depending on how you look at it I will
flee I will focus on primarily today the
issue of the immigrant Muslim youth not
as a way of sidelining the issues of
indigenous Muslim youth but to point out
that where we have the most to gain and
the most to lose right now is with the
immigrant youth because they frankly fit
the profile when we look at what has
happened around the world and all of the
violent actions in the extremism that
have a tip been attached to the name of
Islam they have been created and
characterized by the face of immigrants
they have not been characterized by the
face of indigenous African American
Latino other groups that make up an
important segment of our community so
for that reason I focus on this
population because what does it mean
when you fit the profile
I had interns this summer we have a
year-round intern program every time a
new batch comes in I look at the young
men who come in and I say what does it
feel like to fit the profile what does
it feel like when you walk down the
street and you have a beard or you have
a CUFI or you have dark skin or you are
notice noticeably Muslim even though I
wear hijab it's not the same for me
Muslim women aren't seen as a threat
they're seen as oppressed the what's put
upon me is different than what's put
upon young Muslim men particularly after
the London bombings which highlighted or
I should say that galvanized this this
suspicion that that homegrown terrorism
could take place here within that notion
immigrant Muslim youth when I talked to
them across this country say that they
find themselves truly in a catch-22 they
find that when they are here in the US
with their families where they've grown
up in their natural habitat and
surroundings that they are not viewed as
being fully American and when they're in
their parents homeland visiting or
spending extended periods there they are
viewed only as American or they are not
being viewed as being entirely of that
place that presents an interesting
challenge to a young person what it says
to them and what it can do it can negate
their own sense of any identity they may
have because when they find themselves
equally comfortable in both settings but
not fully accepted in either setting
what does that say to them about who
they are and what an American Muslim
identity means to them can you fit
comfortably within an American Muslim
identity if you are not seen as being
fully American or you do not perceive
that you are seen as being fully
American by your American neighbors and
if you do not think that you were fully
perceived as being in my case
Montenegrin when you go to Montenegro
that presents what could be not only a
cultural clash but a psychological clash
with this background one of the projects
that impacted after the London bombings
was we aim to understand rather than to
describe prematurely the sentiments of
American Muslim youth so what we did was
to conduct a survey during the isne
convention in Chicago over Labor Day
weekend we pulled 200 young American
Muslims under the age of 29 which fell
within the parameters of what Cornell
told us and we asked them questions that
focused on these three key areas the
issues of Islamic education where do you
get it what counts what matters more
than another the issues of excuse me my
mind went length the
issues of identity how do you see
yourself how do you define your own
identity and finally the issue of civic
participation does it matter
is it necessary what does it mean to you
in this process as we conducted the
survey as we as analyze the results of
this survey we found some very
interesting results and some that
frankly surprised us as well for most
among those is that in the area of of
Islamic education we found that these
youth between the ages of 15 and 29 said
that they that in the area of Islamic
education that they received the most
part of their Islamic education from a
mosque setting 69% said that they
received their Islamic education from
from their mosque or their home so it's
within that private circle and then
interestingly 68% said that they
believed that the jurisprudence the
fifth the Sharia that is developed in
the US by Muslim scholars is just as
legitimate as the Sharia the Fick that
is developed in the Muslim world I think
that that is a very promising statistic
it says to us that our young people see
that what comes out of American Muslim
scholars is is just as legitimate as
what comes out of other parts of the
world that shows a sense of
acknowledgement and of empowerment on
the question of identity and this was
the central finding of this study and it
really raises more questions than it
presents answers but the central finding
of the study was the on the question do
you feel a conflict between your
American identity and your Muslim
identity we found that 56 percent said
that they felt no conflict between their
American identity and their Muslim
identity that is both promising and
troubling because we're just over half
and when we further analyze these
results we found that fewer females 41
percent than males 52 percent felt
conflict between their American and
their Muslim identities so that goes
right back to what I was saying in terms
of you
Muslim males fitting the profile if you
fit the profile and you see yourself
yourself to be viewed in a certain way
by the broader society that of course
impacts whether you will claim your
American Muslim identity fully or
half-heartedly or not at all further on
the notion of identity seventy percent
of these young people said that they
noticed significant hostility toward
Muslims in the general American public
seventy percent of them and again when
we look at K through 12 and college
settings even we find that this is true
because we're seeing a rise in hate
crimes and hate incidents in these sites
the most vulnerable among us sit within
this age bracket and we have to ask
ourselves what are we doing to serve
them to serve them not to fix them or to
alter them but to serve them and to help
them grow and and and fully embrace who
they are on the question of identity
another interesting thing that came up
is that we found that the younger
respondents the 14 to 18 year olds
reported more identity conflict than the
older respondents who were 25 to 29 so
it really again points to the importance
of us paying more attention to the
youngest among us because they are the
ones who are the most vulnerable and
they can't be left to figure it out on
their own mentorship programs are
necessary across generational projects
things along those lines finally on the
question of civic participation this was
really interesting because in no other
aspect of this survey did we see an
overwhelming yes or no response to any
question or a strongly believe or
anything else but on the question of
civic participation a full ninety nine
percent said that they believe that
national Muslim organizations should
quote engage in dialogue with government
and the general American public to get
our rights another ninety four percent
said that Muslims should be involved in
the American political process even
though they may disagree with the
government's foreign policy a full 94
percent while we rage on and on in our
communities about whether politics are
necessary whether we should vote what
all of these insecurities these
hesitations our young people are
charging ahead and we have to learn to
keep up the pace we have to learn to
match our stride with theirs because
they are moving faster in terms of
integration in terms of fully embodying
their American Muslim identity then is
the broader American Muslim population
within this context when you look at
this survey and it's something that we
are now looking seriously at in terms of
finding ways to really address the
challenges of young people one thing
that happened after London is that I
have two minutes left is that Muslim
student leaders from msas across the
country pulled themselves together and
issued a condemnation of the London
attacks because they saw that these were
homegrown terrorists and the link was
clearly made to themselves if we are to
assess where we are as the Muslim
community and if we're really doing a
State of the Union here I think the
central theme in that State of the Union
is that it's this isn't the time to wake
up we've woken up all of us some of us
more than others where the questions
before 9/11 in terms of engagement in
terms of Islamic education these central
questions were a lot fuzzier they were
they were luxury issues now they are the
central defining issues within our
community and particularly for our young
people that cannot be ignored
the final thing I want to leave you with
is something that I believe
to my very core yes Muslim youth are
facing myriad challenges they're facing
myriad conflicts they're facing a number
of questions that we don't know yet how
to deal with and they may not yet know
how to ask but these Muslim youth are in
the best position to help themselves and
to advance the cause of not only our
American Muslim community but the global
Muslim community and this is why I
believe that is true these young people
who are not fully accepted of being
American by their fellow Americans not
in every case at least and who are not
fully accepted as being of their
homeland have in common between each
other their lowest common denominator or
even their highest common denominator is
two factors the fact that they all grew
up here in America and they see their
future in America and the fact that they
are all Muslim so the question of
whether we claim an American Muslim
identity it's a moot point we are all
American we are all Muslim whether you
choose to put a hyphen or a plus or a
minus between those two words those are
facts and we have to embrace those facts
and I think that something that Martin
Luther King once said that is not
commonly commonly spread or isn't
commonly known to be attributed to him
speaks directly to the situation of
American Muslim youth Martin Luther King
said human salvation lies in the hands
of the creatively maladjusted human
salvation lies in the hands of the
creatively maladjusted I believe that
American Muslim youth are the creatively
maladjusted we are working in a set of
circumstances a set of parameters a set
of challenges that are unlike any that
we have faced in the past as a community
all together so many different
backgrounds so many different racial and
ethnic and
Tirion backgrounds but we are all facing
it together if there is to be a solution
if there is to be progress that takes
place it will come at the hands of the
American Muslim youth so it is time that
our community not not just tolerate the
young in our populations but that we
push them forward that we create
opportunities for them that we do not
limit their possibilities among those
who are creatively maladjusted doctrine
young so notably mentioned Muslim
comedians these are creatively
maladjusted people you take a crazy set
of circumstances and if you can come out
with the best possible solution of the
best possible way to address the
challenges that you deal with comedy is
the best way to go about it those who
are creatively maladjusted in our
community are those who are embarking on
new and exciting projects and
professions they are comedians they are
actors they are journalists they are
heading a new and interesting territory
so my final charge to you my mandate to
you my plea to you is be among the
creatively maladjusted embrace it
embrace your American Muslim identity
and move forward thank you very much
that I'm on April
[Music]
Thank You Gina we'll speak about this
maladjustment later we have an office
meeting soon after this the the next
speaker is a friend a friend of mine
personally and honored a friend of the
Muslim community and the threat of all
the communities who are potentially
subject to injustice and she lived loyal
to that friendship in the most elegant
and successful way
Constance rice is renowned in her
unconventional approach to tackling
problems of inequity and exclusion
she works in very creative way
well-adjusted law with the LAPD for
example supporting them and at the same
time exposing police brutality with no
hesitation supporting them when they do
good and collecting them if things are
not in the right way she the lady had
more than 50 awards she litigated
quality gated class action civil rights
cases winning more than 1.6 billion this
is a B billion in policy changes and
remedies during our nine-year tenure
with NAACP Legal Defense and Educational
Fund a very special person and the
impact is honored that she is a member
of the family of impact and we are
honored that she's here Constance
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning thank you for that generous
introduction
I'm immigrant and convert and native
Muslim population here
three years later under the tutelage of
dr. Hutton's Salaam and Edina and others
I can say I know next to nothing not
exactly nothing but I come with the same
humility understanding my extreme
limitations in terms of my fluency I do
come as a friend and I want to pick up
on what this amazing panel several of
the themes of this amazing panel has set
out for you and I want to push the
envelope and surely be shocked I'm gonna
push the envelope a little further when
I look at the journey you have taken it
is with some all and a great deal of
fear ah that with grace and flexibility
in the face of danger you have extended
and opened up and said to Americans do
not fear us we are American and we are
Muslim and if we aren't American yet we
are here and we will get there and I
would like to share with you that my
family we are black Brahmins African
American divas and princes
I am the great-granddaughter of slaves
and slave owners and Indian chiefs we
are sue we are Seminole we are Irish we
are British
we are Ghanaian Senegalese and we are
also geeky you see Condoleezza has that
gap in her teeth
I used to have it too until my wisdom
teeth came in that is the geechie gap it
is the DNA marker that we came from the
African tribes that lived off of the
coast of North Carolina
it also partially explains the red hair
and the freckles but we are America 19th
century America blended my family we
have been in the slave owners households
for a hundred years and my family parts
of it have been here for 10,000 years if
you count my Native American ancestry
and yet we are still the other so that
is just a warning get used to it if
they're just now getting accustomed to
having their own half relatives for I am
Sally Hemings Conda Lisa and I are Sally
Hemings we have lived in their
households we have shared their
bloodlines and we're still not
recognized as Americans so your journey
don't feel alone in their journey the
lady who was a Polish descent who lived
next to my mother's mother in Reading
Pennsylvania never learned to speak
English but we communicated by baking
bread and mic she would hand us polish
dumplings and my grandmother would hand
her southern baked rolls and they would
hang each other's clothes up on the
clothesline and they could never
communicate in any language except love
the language of neighbors it is an
extremely long journey in America is a
rolling experiment she is the grandest
human mix-up assimilation integration
experiment that we've ever seen in the
history of womankind and Samuel
Huntington has it wrong you don't worry
about American culture because there is
no one American culture there is no one
American religion it is of the many one
our greatest credo is e pluribus unum of
the many one of the many means no one
need lose their music their core
identity from Nero country of origin you
need not lose your food your cuisine you
need not lose your perspective
politically religiously economically or
any other way
the many it means we're going to be a
salad bowl not a puree it means it's
okay to have Irish pubs and yet March in
the Veterans Day Parade it's okay for
African Americans to change their name
every 20 years we've gone from colored
Negro african-american black and now
back to African American III claim them
all I'm not gonna worry about it
we'd all be in therapy if we focus too
much on that stuff what I'm suggesting
is in a time of danger you are grappling
with alienated youth and the questions
of integration and many of the other
themes that were chased for you in the
state of Muslim Americans and American
Muslims you are not alone every
community in this country goes through
it but you are going through it at a
particularly dangerous time now as a
lawyer
they call me Darth Vader because I'm
always painting the worst picture I
don't like my clients to be unprepared
and so I end up focusing on the worst
case scenario and I don't want to scare
people I just want them to be ready for
the worst case I want my clients to be
able to defend themselves I want them to
understand they have to be able to see
around corners and they have to be ten
steps ahead of the frightened people who
were in charge of this country right now
when 9/11 happened and my father was on
the phone for me
with me he was in Connecticut and he's a
turn on the television and we were
watching as the second time I actually
worked on the 81st floor of tower two
when I worked for the State Department
of Law for the state of New York I went
to NYU Law School and as we didn't know
what we were seeing when that tower
crumbled and my father who is an Air
Force colonel at a military man was
screaming scramble the f-16s scramble
the f-16s where are the f-16s NORAD
should know he did
NORAD and I was calling from my dad as I
was coming out of the shock and and he
was there was no nothing on the phone I
thought perhaps he'd had a heart attack
or something he wasn't so I'm screaming
dad dad dad and my mother picks up the
phone and she says will you please stop
screaming on my telephone I said where
is my father what happened to me she
says he's downstairs he's getting his
uniform on he thinks he's going to
scramble the f-16s she told him the only
thing he was scrambling was his eggs
that morning but he thought he was going
to defend the country my father spent
his whole life defending this nation and
he is appalled at what he sees as the
reaction in and by this country to tell
you the truth I'm a little relieved that
the reactions haven't been more
draconian because after calling my
father I called Ramona Ripstein at the
ACLU and I said Ramona Korematsu is not
happening again on our watch
we are not going to have concentration
camps we are not going to stand idly by
and we are not going to permit the
Supreme Court to sanction the rounding
up of Muslims and Muslim Americans we
cannot have what happened to the
Japanese happen to these communities and
Ramona said you're absolutely right then
we realized we had absolutely no
connection to any of you who have
wouldn't know how to help you if it
wouldn't even know whom to call to help
and that began the journey of me finding
connections to these many very important
communities and I say important and
here's where I'm asking you to consider
pushing the envelope the United States
of America is not the issue the issue is
the soul of Islam this is a battle for
the meaning of Islam in modernity who
defines that is not going to be non
Muslim Americans
and it is not going to be resolved with
nation state war machinery
you can't invade your way out of this
you can't bomb your way out of this
you can't occupy your way out of this
this is a fundamental battle for hearts
and minds in this country too because
getting back to my point that it is not
a battle of cultures the United States
of America is a cauldron of cultures
there is one credo it is a credo of
Liberty freedom responsibility it is a
credo of equality in equality of
opportunity we are Americans because we
believe in that credo we are not
Americans because we are Christian or
Muslim or Buddhist we are not Americans
because of anything else we are
Americans because of that credo of the
many one many cultures one credo people
who don't believe in freedom need to go
someplace else but people have many
religions and of no religion are welcome
here this set of communities Muslim
Americans American Muslims are the
vanguard because the United States does
not know how to solve this problem
and it will thrash around dangerously
until there is a solution and one of the
things that I ask you with great
humility I ask you is to put our heads
together to come up with the solution
because the next time this country gets
hit on its soil as London got hit that
will be when the real dangerous period
starts because nothing that they've done
works
they have done nation state war they
have tried to go after the people they
have identified by name its belonging to
extremists terrorist groups they don't
have the information they don't have the
relationships they don't have the human
intelligence they don't as I said to my
FBI friends two of them I was debating
this with them I said what are you
talking about you can't even figure out
with homegrown Negroes who's who you
can't figure out who is a gang member
and who isn't and we're your neighbors
and relatives how are you going to go to
a country you don't speak the language
you don't know a darn thing about the
tribes you have no concept of their
history and you're gonna go there and
tell who's who
Oh get a grip time for a reality check
it's not going to happen you could knock
down all the doors in Baghdad you are
not going to figure out who's who it's
not happening and in some of the
mountain regions even the Pakistani
leadership and establishment can't
figure out who's who how in the world
are westernized Americans who can't even
figure out their own minority population
is going to figure this out they can't
and that's dangerous because that means
we must and we've got to offer a
solution that fights on the fronts that
can be fought on in the United States is
neglecting if we don't come up with a
solution that the American people can
look at and say you know what this will
get us there this will pull the plug out
of the ideology this will win the hearts
and minds this will stop the alienation
of youth this agenda of alienation
reduction full inclusion fluency amongst
these different cultures this agenda of
hearts and minds this agenda of what the
battle for modern Islam looks like and
how it can be won can be the blueprint
that can stop the next panic
because when this country panics it does
stupid things and when it does stupid
things the scapegoat group gets it I
don't want us to get to that point so in
addition to the agenda that has been
laid out here a very important agenda
for reclaiming your youth reducing the
alienation integrating becoming more
politically active the thing that I fear
also is that you don't have the
political capital and you don't have the
representation you don't have your
praetorian guard when African Americans
at the turn of the last century were
just coming out and we're still facing
Black Codes in Jim Crow and my family
faced a lynching for opening up schools
to teach slaves out of how to read when
we had no political representation no
voice we were subject to physical
intimidation and a lynching campaign and
outright murder and states like
Mississippi were run by terrorists
terrorists who known as the Klan they
were the Attorney General and the
governor and they ran all the courts we
could go nowhere we had no courts the
only thing we had was our church it was
our Christianity and from there we built
a political base but it took years and
years and it took court battles you had
a legal battle you had a legal phalanx
you had a civic grassroots movement that
took 50 years and after World War 2 and
black soldiers came back after
liberating Europe and they came back and
we're told to sit in the back of the bus
they just had it they said no more and
that was the beginning with our sports
and our entertainment leaders like Harry
Belafonte and Jackie Robinson in every
sector of American society we had a
group that was ready to carry the
message that we are not second-class
citizens we are not X slaves we are
first-class Americans and we're going to
take our seat in the front of the bus
that movement had to have those Civic
institutions you had to have your
lawyers you had to have your act your
scholars whom you have but I want
us to think seriously do you have enough
of these other fronts fortified and
staffed and ready to go because if we
turn the next corner and this country
panics because it's what it's been doing
is not going to work and can't work on
his face we had better be ready to
suggest what will that is something that
is frightening to think about you can't
do it alone and it is our obligation is
non-muslim Americans to stand with you
and to help you think this through and
to build your connections so that you
get so integrated into the fabric and so
familiar that we am non-muslim Americans
no longer look at you solely through the
lens as post 11 threats the United
States Americans barely know their own
history they're not going to know that
you've been here for decades some of you
who have been here for 50 years the
Southern California Muslim American and
Muslim immigrant community is is at
least 30 years old but the larger
society doesn't know they only know you
from September 11th 2001 and that is a
tragedy but it is the reality to counter
that is going to take an aggressive
campaign an aggressive campaign that
repositions Muslim Americans American
Muslims and the immigrant communities
that you are part of it is going to take
an aggressive campaign but internally
you've got to agree on what that message
is and it's gonna have to be done
American style and you're gonna have to
figure out how to get the translators I
am spending time with you so that I can
help you translate and there need to be
a hundred and fifty of people like me
who are willing to spend the time to
understand how you want to be translated
and how you want to be represented it's
not up to me as to how that's done it is
up to you I'm suggesting that we get
ready for after the next shoe drops
and it's going to take a unity of will a
lot of the things that we had the luxury
of fighting over we no longer have the
luxury of fighting over this is not a
sociological or general integration
discussion this is a survival discussion
and as an attorney I want my clients to
understand that while you may not face
that peril
you've got to get ready for it you're
already on your way you have some great
you have some terrific lawyers they've
been doing magnificent work I'll never
forget confronting the FBI guys I said
okay what were you thinking because
their own Inspector General found that
right after nine nine eleven two days
after the FBI were going through the
streets of Manhattan looking for taxi
drivers who looked Muslim that was the
state of their intelligence it's in
their own inspector general report
Michael in fine it's just astounding the
stuck on stupid stuff that they did
that's what panic produces they were
panicked they had no information and
what did they do they went through the
streets of Manhattan looking for taxi
drivers who might look Muslim which
meant they were looking for turbans
don't even understand Sikhs aren't
Muslim that's the kind of ignorant that
is a dagger aimed at the throat of these
communities and I shouldn't say these
communities as you say our communities
because if you are endangered than I am
endangered and I'm putting this as part
of the agenda and respectfully
suggesting that we find a way to
incorporate it and your leaders are
thinking along these lines but I want to
quicken the pace get the action
blueprint the one thing I know how to do
I
I can be of no help in any religion
discussion of any faith whatsoever I am
useless on that front what I do know how
to do is fight I know how to fight and I
know how to survive and I want to help
you think through that blueprint you are
going to be the salvation of this
country in this
it is this community that is going to
have to lead the rest of this country
and the rest of the Muslim world you are
the ones who can define Islam in a
winning way that endangers no one and
yet pulls the jet fuel that is Fanning
the extremists and cult of destruction
that is masking as Islam this community
and I hate to lay this on you just as
the civil rights movement was laid on
the shoulders of the intellectual elite
and the religious elite of the African
American community and we had to create
a vision and a strategy that pulled the
plug on the terrorists who hanged us
from trees you are that community not
just for the United States but for the
entire world
and so it is with great humility that I
lay this terrible burden on you that you
already know you have but I just wanted
to take a moment today to frame it in
its most stark terms I want us to be
ready I want us to be able to talk to
the United States in a way that will
keep it from panicking and show it the
real way of solving the set of dilemmas
and in the process you will not only
have led yourselves which you will be
leading this entire country it is a
privilege to be here my learning curve
is steep I beg your indulgence and your
patience but I my one message today is
that the state of the union of Muslim
Americans is one of advancement and
peril and I want to be ready for both
thank you it's been an honor to address
you
for the victus game happen
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much your suggestion is
as you know already taken
you have been retained and we don't pay
and you'll be asked to pay so we are
yeah it is always always a treat to
listen to Constance and she has been
very true to every word she said she is
working very closely with us to achieve
what she has been recommending I have
good news and bad news the good news no
time for questions the bad news we will
not cancel the time for lunch
but please submit your questions in
writing and we'll find away I think this
is the time for that okay yeah I'll ask
Ozma to come and nayer dr. Nayar ali-a
part of what we heard from all the
speakers really is the battle for the
soul of Islam and Constance put it very
squarely that no one can win this battle
no one can fight this battle but us part
of that is this book that you will find
out and I'll ask those who contributed
heavily to make this book a reality Ozma
and nayer Ali to give you a few words
about the book
is not becoming that my name on the book
and I made propaganda for it but for
sure the money goes to impact and the
book will be signed out during the
lunchtime assalamu alaikum
at the first impact convention 2001 we
had a noted human rights activists from
iran ibrahim Yazzie who came to our
convention and was the keynote speaker
there he was speaking about the human
rights movement in Iran and in private
discussions with us he said that there
needs to be a Muslim champion a Muslim
voice for human rights and he said that
this has to be a Muslim voice based in
Muslim sources in a Muslim standard not
simply a copycat of Amnesty
International or Human Rights Watch or
the UN Universal Declaration of Human
Rights all of which are wonderful
organizations and secular documents
looking at human rights but one that
looks from a Muslim perspective and this
made me think back to a to a hutzpah I
heard when I was a teenager and most of
the time I don't really hear much when I
go to hood bus but this time I was
actually paying attention and the Imam
was speaking and I can still remember
this it was when I was about 14 or so he
was speaking about Islam and human
rights and he said that Islam brought
all the human rights to humanity 1,400
years ago and I was thinking at the time
well what is he talking about it doesn't
say in the Koran freedom of speech it
doesn't say in the Koran freedom of
religion the way it says it in the US
Bill of Rights it doesn't use that
language but over the years I continue
to think about what the Imam was trying
to get out and then when Ibrahim used he
made this challenge to us we decided as
an organization that we were going to do
this so we were going to go and look at
human rights from a Muslim perspective
and when we decided to do that we
realized this was a huge task this was
not something that we could do in one
two days this was gonna require a real
serious study and and to do that
this was four years ago now we embarked
on a process we got scholars we got the
input of a lot of people with an impact
doctoral - took the lead on this and
over the last four years we wrote a book
that looks at all of these issues and
this book in pursuit of justice is being
published and now is finally available
for sale it's outside doctoral - we'll
be signing the copies I'm going to ask
Osama who did much of the research to
make some comments about her involvement
in this now thank you Isana cone good
morning Thank You mayor for giving me
this opportunity to be here it's good to
see that all our hard work and efforts
over the last three years have finally
come to fruition I'm just a bit worried
about myself
I'm Canadian I'm a Montrealer I'm an
academic researcher currently with the
trans cultural research unit affiliated
with McGill at the time that I first
came to know about this project I had
just finished my master's in Poli Sci
from Miguel and I was affiliated with
the Arab and Middle East Studies
Institute there I spent a year working
with Maher long-distance communicating
by phone and by email primarily and I
didn't actually meet any of the impact
members until the convention two years
ago right here but we did the research I
did the research in the writing of the
book a complete first draft in the first
six months and then there and I
continued to work together for rising
and completing a second draft by the end
of that year just two things about how I
guess why I came to be involved with
this I was really intrigued by the
questions that MPAC was asking at the
time when I first heard about it I think
as progressive Muslims we are still in
the early stages of creating a body of
literature scholarly based literature
that engages with historically defined
notions of the relationship between
Islam
State in the community my understanding
of the book was that it was meant to be
contribution towards this end and I
believe it does successfully achieve
this and I hope that once you read it
you all agree with us too the other
thing is that I from my own research
which is focused on understanding how
religion is used as a political tool to
construct and deconstruct Muslim
communities and societies I saw the need
and the importance to have a theoretical
framework for human rights and
islamically oriented theoretical
framework so that we can critique
violations in Muslim countries and to be
able to set up the argument and to
support it
using the Quran as our basis for our
argument this the using the Quran this
leads me to sort of the in a third point
about methodology and sources and dr.
haataja and jazzer can speak maybe in
more detail about that but primarily
we've situated our arguments with the
Quran as a starting point and then going
on to religious and academic sources you
know as necessary and I I think we are
well aware of the subjectivity of
interpretation but I think it is
important to also emphasize individual
reasoning and an interpretive process as
part of the component by which you well
we wrote it and I hope with which you
will read it as well the flexibility in
that process I think that is what is
most important that is a symbolic of
what we meant to achieve I think this is
what MPAC is also trying to do in its
work
more generally and I hope it's what you
will receive and be able to contribute
to as well as in furthering discourse
and discussion on these issue in your
communities lastly just thinking about
there reflecting on the initial vision
of the book I mean this is three years
ago that I wrote it and we I've been
working worked with impact for that one
year I know that some things have
changed primarily the environment in
which we're living in has changed but I
think the book is still highly relevant
and highly important today particularly
because the nature of discourse
and about Muslims in contemporary Canada
and America has become very politically
charged and makes it necessary I think
all of the more so for us to examine and
engage with these issues of what faith
means what our religion means what our
rights are what they should be as we
define our own evolving identities and
our own evolving place as Muslims within
our communities thank you okay so in
short this book is is formed of 16
chapters ended by a conclusion and our
approach was basically coming from our
awareness that Islam in its originality
and the purity articulated in the Quran
could transform life completely within a
time span of 30 years this is when there
was no telephones tax machines jet
flights who that think that Blackberry
and all all the things that reduces the
time and the distance so if you factor
that in that means that a book came
changed everything within about five
minutes if we if we make the time
equivalent so and that book did not just
disappear it stayed here then we found
that he's not working anymore that
actually was the nagging point why did
it happen and it is not happening and of
course the discovery will be very easy
that we are not taking Quran we are
taking how sheer so-and-so and Imams
also seized the Quran so it is a huge
current of
electricity that electrified the world
but now it stops at first transformer to
reduce it to 120 watts second transfers
of six watts last transformer to heat
know what's whatsoever and and so the
challenge to the Muslim mind is to be
able to rediscover the Quran directly
and so our methodology was to depend the
heavily on the Quran respecting the
Arabic grammar so that the
interpretation does not become
completely loose and looking into
wherever and whenever Prophet peace be
upon him explained things all other
sources a very rich heritage of exegesis
is respected and used but is not binding
what is binding is as foreign summarized
in a very eye-opening verse that the
froth will be swept away and what is
good for people will stay and last and
as a Bidoof ajamu java and why am i am
vanessa i am could fulfill art so we
look at the quran has the father of at
well the the poet and philosopher and
the founder of Pakistan once told him
read the Quran as if it is revealed to
you so to rediscover that to reconnect
to replug into the source without
transformers was the challenge and the
based on that we came with the issues
that are nagging in our minds the issue
of rights of women that have been
violated the issue of right of
minorities that have been violated the
issues of right of majorities that have
been violated and and all the the
critical
and somehow embarrassing issues that the
traditional institution is avoiding we
decided to storm in and just storming in
is the major step because it is an
invitation for further literature
research and work to be done from the
American soil
within that context to find our way
around will the book is available we'll
be outside and I hope that you you like
it and if you don't let us know also
because this itself is enriching thank
you very much so the fairest puppy of
the book will go as a gift from impact
to constance rice
[Music]
[Applause]